[Music]
so referred to bending reality is
understanding how people view losses and
games and there's nobel-prize-winning
behavioral economics theory that says
that people value put a value of losses
on at least twice when an equivalent
gain is and that's how people get their
valuations distorted and actually the
guys that came up with that theory said
it's twice as losses are twice as heavy
as gains but then they've unofficially
said you know really it's five to seven
times as much we just wrote down twice
as much because we wanted fewer
arguments so losing five dollars stings
at least twice as much as gaining five
dollars losing five dollars feels like
losing ten dollars or even thirty five
dollars it's just a ridiculous skewing
in our brains over loss which is why
when you're when you're pitching a game
if you think that what you're offering
is worth a hundred dollars and you're
only charging 80 well based on prospect
theory is in it they're not going to
make that exchange well to us that makes
all the sense in the world because it's
a game but if 80 losing it paying eighty
dollars for something it's got to be
worth at least 160 dollars for them to
want it's this crazy math that goes on
in our heads over gains and loss gains
and losses it just did there's nothing
we can do about it so understanding that
first of all when I begin to use an
accusations on it to try to diminish
those fears of loss it gets a person
back more into even games and then I
realize that people are more likely to
do things to avoid losses in the
negotiation all I have to point out is
what's actually going to be lost if this
isn't done in some ways in the business
world a reverse of this is what I call
taking people hostage to the future if I
can convince you that if you do all this
work for me for nothing
that you all this business will come
your way as a result which is actually
what's done a lot in the business
community you know come and do this
business for us had a cut rate and we'll
introduce you to all this business and
you'll be fabulously wealthy as a result
of our referrals well if you can buy
into getting all that money for those
referrals now you're being taken hostage
to the future and you'll do the business
for nothing because you're afraid of
losing those referrals that's pretty
common and after a while people tend to
catch on to it the much wiser approach
is for me to simply point out how not
doing this deal is in fact costing you
every day if you do nothing you lose if
you don't address this issue it's going
to cost you so when the status quo
becomes laws and people are more likely
to make a decision to make a move
because of prospect theory just the fear
of loss in our head is huge
[Music]